hi there steve kaufman today i want to
talk about the use of dictionaries in
language learning but before i get to
that subject i want to ask you what it
is you would like to see me talk about
in these videos
i used to make longer videos more
rambling videos eight ten minutes long
now i've gone to a shorter formula some
people have told me they would rather
see some longer ones some people say
they'd like me to talk about politics
you know the us primaries or
uh you know the refugee situation in
europe or or the middle east or ukraine
um
i know some people use these as a source
of encouragement for these for their own
language learning but some people who
are not native speakers of english use
them for you know to improve their
english as listening and reading
material since we provide transcripts so
please let me know what you would like
to see in these videos i'm going to try
to do them twice a week i could do one
short one one long one
anyway i'm interested in hearing your
opinion now let's get to dictionaries
a lot of people place a lot of
importance on the dictionary
they like certain dictionaries they read
dictionaries
some people like monolingual
dictionaries so if they're learning
french they want the dictionary to be
french french monolingual the same
the explanation in the same language as
the language they're learning
personally
i'm not a
that interested in dictionaries
dictionaries are a resource
to help me get through my content
because as you know i'm
a content based
language learner input listening and
reading
historically before the age of the
internet and online dictionaries
i would look words up in an ordinary
dictionary and as i've said many times
no sooner do i close the dictionary than
i've already forgotten the meaning that
i found there
now by reading online
especially at the beginning stage in the
language we can immediately access the
meaning with online dictionaries that's
a lot better because if you have to
spend you know 10 20 seconds or in the
case of a chinese dictionary even longer
to find the word and then you forget it
very quickly that's not very efficient
so to me the only requirement of a
dictionary is that it contain
an explanation for the word that i'm
looking for
i recognize that the explanation there
will not tell the whole story it may not
even be relevant to the text that i'm
reading i find that particularly the
case for korean where very often the
dictionary explanation in naver which is
a very good korean dictionary in fact
doesn't correspond to the context that
i'm reading so to me the dictionary
definition is often just a hint
to get me through hopefully in many
cases not always to get me through the
text that i'm reading
and i know that if i meet that word
again and again and again eventually
i'll form a picture of the scope of
meaning of that word and how it's used
so i don't really rely on the dictionary
you know at times i have opened the
dictionary to kind of read through it
and see how many words i know and it
seems very interesting to to discover
new words in the dictionary but and the
dictionary has the advantage that
they're in alphabetical order
very often so that you can see related
words lined up one behind the other or
below the other
but the point is that not very much of
that sticks
if i can't remember a word that i looked
up in the dictionary
which is related to a context
i can't even remember it for 20 seconds
how much am i going to retain of what i
read in a dictionary not very much so
i don't think that's a very useful way
to spend my time and the same is true of
the monolingual dictionary if i look
something up and the explanation is in
polish and the explanation contains
two more words in polish that i don't
understand then i'm going to look up
those polish words and that explanation
will have more words in it that i don't
understand
um
and some uh abstract concepts are very
difficult to to explain so i'm not a fan
of of monolingual dictionaries so to me
the ideal dictionary is the online
dictionary uh if i'm reading away from
the computer reading a book i come
across words that i don't understand in
most cases i just move on and forget
about it hoping that one day i will come
across that word in my online reading
and be able to look it up i have on
occasion saved up lists of words and and
then looked them up put them into link
and it i never continue doing it it just
doesn't seem to be worth the effort so
that's my picture on how i use
dictionaries be interested in your
comments and also would like to know
what you would like to see
in my videos so thank you for listening
bye for now